hello everyone
welcome to rational science from
frankfurt germany
and today i'm here with my youngest son
ans
my partner here uh the manager the boss
so i gotta be today i gotta behave
today we're gonna do a little uh review
of the year
and um and then i'm going to open the
floor up for questions
uh any questions comments that you want
to make i'm going to try to answer them
online and uh
hans here is going to try to read them
out for us okay
so um let's get started here okay
one of the issues i guess the primary
issue we got today is the following here
we go
okay and it's uh we're in the
year uh 2020 some people say that it's
the last year
we lost a lot of economics so
yeah i flattened you out uh
and the question is whether 2021 is the
last
year not already already guesses 2023
uh that's my you know i mean uh maybe
that baby that's
punching his card in there he's gonna
have a bout of progeria and maybe die in
july or something
you know some that's one of the things
you want to consider one of the things
you want to ask questions about today
okay the extinction issue and then
there's another issue
and it's uh this one and that's uh
whether you know yeah they're used there
was a civil war
in 1860 to 1865
and the question is what that was just
the first civil war like there was world
war one world war
ii are we going to have a civil war one
in civil war
ii okay in those days it was north
against south
and today the map looks pretty much the
same except that maybe you could add
some of the
central states uh you got east
and west against the center so so to
speak center south maybe
okay so maybe that's one of the things
you got to consider uh
will there be another civil war uh if uh
either if
trump stays or if he goes whichever way
will there be a civil war
and if there is a civil war will that uh
fulfill the uh the prediction uh
saying that this is the last year
2021 and let me give you an idea here
uh what i'm referring to in case uh
uh you know there is a civil war this is
what you can expect
okay these are the icbm silos in the
united states and
you would have the eastern and western
throwing against the middle
some general here and another general
over there okay that's one possibility
uh you know it happened uh with the
romans uh they hired
the barbarians some of the visigoths and
so on
and you know eventually those were the
ones who overthrew the
the roman empire okay so yeah it could
happen it could be internal
these are the naval bases the united
states has and here i think the
east and west have an advantage because
for some reason there are no ships in
kansas
[Laughter]
i don't know why but there might be one
okay and uh these are the air force
bases i'm sure that they're not all
there
wait so is this all need to know basis
or is this top secret
this is all see i got it directly from
the cia okay and so you can see where
the bases are
uh maybe here they're pretty much equal
you know
could there be a war who do you think
would win north uh well i think the
middle or the end
i think the east and west again you know
like if you look at the map here
uh where was it again uh the civil war
civil war here you can see it was uh
the maps looked pretty much the same it
was always the north
east and the west against the south
and now all we did was add the central
states
okay so uh not much change the only
thing
you got lincoln versus jeff davis and
now you got uh what uh
trump against um biden
could that happen could that ever happen
okay
okay so let's move on let me get back in
here for a second
okay we're gonna do a year in review uh
essentially i went through and looked at
some of the videos that we put out this
year
okay and here you can see it
let me run it down uh we ended last year
with a
rand and or ein rand of some caller
and we started the year with her uh
first week i think was the last uh we
did with
ein rand and my argument was she was not
a philosopher
why because a philosopher is philosophy
is part of
science and it deals with um
explaining purposes and reasons
whereas physics deals with causes and
mechanisms
okay so there's a difference there and
amrand uh
wittgenstein uh kant uh david hume
russell all these people none of them
were philosophers all they gave were
opinions
okay they did work on language but they
did a lousy job with that as far as i'm
concerned
and we try to correct that here okay
definitions
yeah definitions and so on definitions
primarily but also
analysis of words they did not analyze
it
the way we would do it in science in a
scientific way
okay st thomas aquinas he was a mechanic
we found out
uh why he worked on cars or maybe
stage coaches no he's a mechanic because
the mechanics
borrowed just about everything from
aquinas except that you know they they
don't call them angels anymore they
don't call them spirits
uh they call them particles
[Laughter]
so it's these particles that can be at
two places at once just like thomas
aquinas's angels were two places at once
so he had already discovered the
uncertainty principle you know a long
time ago
science not equal to religion we
analyzed that science and said it's a
little different than religion science
is about explaining uh mechanism
especially in regards to physics which
is what we do here
and religion what is religion well
religion is about opinions and beliefs
it's not about god it's not about you
know you can have uh
you can believe in astrology uh
there are so many beliefs out there you
can believe in spirits and uh
black magic it doesn't have to
necessarily be god
so no is not specifically about god it's
about beliefs everybody has a religion
everybody has a system of beliefs i
remember one good distinction we made
between science and religion was that
with science it's more about presenting
all the possible explanations for
something
whereas religion was picking one
like if someone asked yeah true yeah how
does magnetism work
scientists will give you the five five
theories on it
whereas the the i don't call religious
person but
someone who just wants to sell you a
belief will just give you one of them
believe this believe the second one this
is the the theory that it's true
which theory is true is up to religion
whereas which
what are the theories that one's science
yeah truth
knowledge uh
persuading people oh that's part of
religion
you know and everybody has a tendency to
try to impose his beliefs
his religion on someone else that's just
human nature
and there's nothing wrong with that it's
just that we need to recognize that part
of the presentation as being religion
physics uh science uh philosophy
all those have to do with objective
explanation so that you understand it
not so that you believe it
it's uh religion where they talk about
knowledge and yeah i know
i know god exists and i know that
space time exists and i know that a
particle can be in two places at once
okay so when you know you've got a
religion that's when you don't know that
you're doing fine
okay okay let's continue here
uh in the list um talked about the ether
uh what is ether well it comes from the
greeks and essentially it's a medium
that supposedly is the one that vibrates
or carries
or whichever way you want to phrase it
uh light
okay so it's a vibration of the ether
that forms light it's the vibration
of these so-called particles that form
the ether
so what is the ether well the ether has
always been the same thing
it's been particles bunch of particles
that's the definition of ether
and a lot of people don't like that but
they never tell me what they think ether
is
okay everybody has this different notion
do you mean it's like a
they say that it's an ocean of little
balls no well that's what it is
but some people say well no that's not
it but they never tell me what is they
always tell me what it ain't
and that's the problem and uh
mathematical physics today
deals completely with an ether we never
got rid of the ether
mathematical physics believes that space
is
an ether that's made of particles uh
quantum that's quantum mechanics uh
general relativity has the same
notion the bread and butter the building
block
of general relativity is the event what
is an event
is a point in space time what is the
point
was the sandbox and the point is one of
those grains
and that's what space-time is a bunch of
grains okay so if you've got a different
idea what the ether is
well you better write it down and just
to add on that if you can define the
ether it's obviously not an object
because
objects we point to concepts we define
so if you say the ether
is this and you define it you can't say
that you're going to vibrate it
hold on if you say the ether is an ocean
of little balls then you could point to
it technically
uh no because again that's muriology you
can't
uh uh it's many particles uh okay see
that let's see
okay uh an object is just standalone one
object
two chairs isn't an object you got it
it's a relation
okay um infinite infinity we dealt
with that several weeks and uh what are
we talking about well
infinite is an adjective and adjectives
can only be used in
physics to qualify objects and
all objects are finite so to say that
it's an infinite finite it's an oxymoron
or
it's a self-contradiction what they've
done with this
adjective they turned it into a noun and
when they don't want to answer a
question or they can't answer a question
they send you
all the way to infinity and say why
don't you go to infinity
okay infinity is that place where they
answer questions so go
out there and find them space vacuum
nothing they are synonyms no one has
ever defined it
everybody thinks of space as a physical
object and the way we do it in physics
is
if you think space is a physical object
point to it you've got you
that means you have to show me the shape
and if you show me the shape you got to
show me the contrast what gives it shape
what
what what it contrasts against
okay and so uh you got to you got to
identify that medium as well i guess
we're talking
it uh matter contrast space but the
edges of space
we don't know where it is yeah but
that's the point if it's an object you
gotta have this uh god's view this
bird's eye view and say
look that space over there okay tell me
what's what's the thing that gives it
shape what's on the outside of it
and of course that's a question no one
can answer and that's why uh
mathematical physics has a standard um
answer to that question and it's that uh
it's an unscientific question
because we can't prove it it's existing
what's outside of it i mean one of the
kids when they draw a curved space
they don't talk about what's above the
current yeah if space is a canvas going
down what's the stuff on top of it
not only that when you see the uh the
general relativity the space-time uh
fishnet yeah i want to know what the
black stuff that gives
you know shade teach one of those
strings is and that's the one that they
have trouble
identifying always okay and that's why
they say well it's an unscientific
question
because obviously it's a conceptual
issue this is not a question of um
uh of actually bringing space
some uh to you it's just it's a
conception i i don't have to
i can imagine it just draw it and i can
imagine it and
what the problem is you can't imagine it
because you can't imagine what's outside
of space
giving shape to space if it's made out
of particles
what's the stuff that's on the outside
where the particles end
space space number two i guess extra
space
yeah okay uh so we have a problem with
space and that's a problem in
mathematical physics in general
uh the dimensions of mathematics uh
have nothing to do with dimensions
length width and height what they have
in mathematical physics
is number lines and so one of the
problems there
is that time has been called a dimension
when it's really a number line
time has no direction which is what
number lines have
and it has magnitude and no direction
which is the opposite of what a
dimension is
a dimension doesn't have magnitude but
it does have direction
and the other property of dimensions
real dimension physical dimensions is
that they're
uh orthogonally uh to each other in
other words they
they have orthogonality perpendicularity
with respect to each other well usually
when a dimension is brought up it has a
magnitude
isn't it no that's a five as soon as you
as soon as you have put a magnitude
you're talking about a number line
because if it's got magnitude you can't
put magnitude to direction
you can't say five centimeters five is
pointing in that dirt
four five six seven are pointing in that
direction and that's what you can't say
i mean no four five six seven yeah
direction less that's why a number line
they always put an arrow and people say
okay i understand it's pointing that
direction no number lines don't point in
any direction you can put them in any
direction you want
or you can put the four over here the
five over there and the six over in
another place
it's it's not on a number line it could
be a number
curve for all we know okay there's no
direction to numbers
and that's a serious problem in
mathematics because they do
tend to you know include it as part of
physics they want to show that the math
represents physics when it doesn't
okay math and physics will never meet
okay uh we did a little bit of quite a
bit in fact throughout the year on
quantum mechanics it's entirely
irrational it's completely religion why
because they they have an
irrational atom okay what's the problem
with the atom well the atom
is um we can't explain why the electron
bead
does not fall to the nucleus or leave
the
atoms spontaneously why do you need to
ionize in other words with some kind of
external force
why do you need to ionize an atom pull
its electron out
what holds it what holds it in its orbit
to begin with that's the issue
why does it fall to the nucleus why does
it fly away same with the earth by the
way why does it fall to the sun why does
it fly out of the solar system
same issues in both cases no one can
explain
what keeps those things at a distance at
the same place
you know orbiting in in the same place
all the time i heard there's ropes to
tie them together
[Laughter]
uh the particle uh quantum is not a
particle it's not a corpuscle it's not a
grain of dust
what is a particle a particle is a
number what they're doing is
uh accelerating and smashing quantities
amounts uh number fives and against
number tens
or whatever uh virtual particles
that's magic that's black magic the
particles just come in from the void
uh you have black a black black particle
black particle comes against the white
particle turns into a no particle
okay or uh black ball with white ball
turned into no ball
and then the no ball can separate into
black ball and white swan
what the hell is this so you reject the
notion
of matter coming out of nothing and
nothing and matter turning into nothing
yeah what what what they've done is they
cannot explain
certain aspects especially what happens
in this
subatomic microscopic world so they
what do they say they say well well we
cannot account for the energy there's
got to be a conservation of energy
second law of thermodynamics okay
so there's got to be a a conservation of
energy they can't justify
what they see in the chamber they say oh
we know it came out of the vacuum inside
the chamber
that's where the extra energy came what
do you mean the energy
well it's these particles you see and
what is a particle it's just pure energy
it's a quantum
of energy an amount of energy and this
energy now is in the equation we say
okay we can put that
that five extra kilo electron volts or
whatever
inside the equation we're okay now we've
got the conservation of energy
but then the explanation is the problem
where
did it come from and they say well it
came from the vacuum because see the
vacuum we know it's
it's got a seething
energy that's what the vacuum is which
is wet particles
particles and anti-particles which
combine to form nothing which is made
out of particles
i hope you got all that right the test
on friday okay
i'll say eight good questions for after
the recap yeah yeah
so keep the uh
we're gonna scroll later on and look at
the questions okay anyways uh let me
continue here okay
um entanglement how a particle affects
another one at a distance they can't
explain that with particles
and so entanglement is just magic
superposition two particles at the same
place the coherence particle at two
places at once etc
uh so they invented all these principles
the principle complementarity of
uncertainty uh the exclusion principle
they've got all these principles that
form the foundations of quantum
mechanics
and all these principles are irrational
i always like to say the uncertainty
principle which is also known as
indeterminacy
uh what is it it says that when the ball
moves it doesn't stand still
and when the ball stands still it
doesn't move that's what that's that's
what heisman
he demonstrated that mathematically so
it's proven okay
so believe it uh they invented that they
invented the higgs
which is another great particle it's the
particle of mass
okay it's like the particle of weight
okay
if you can figure that one out and then
the graviton they're still looking for
it they've been looking for it for 500
years and
they're going to get up here
general relativity also entirely
irrational why they have black holes
wormholes
i love the wormholes they go right
through space which is nothing
and end up in another universe which is
part of ours
what uh
dark matter uh they can't explain the
gravity what the
galaxy rotation problem why the stars on
the outside of a galaxy
travel faster than the ones on the
inside it's like saying that pluto can
travel faster than
mercury and you say well that's
counterintuitive yeah it is
and that's what a galaxy does so how do
you explain it with galaxies well they
but they did they sprinkled all these
dark kilograms on the outskirts of the
the perimeter of a galaxy and they say
see we fixed it
well you fixed it mathematically the
question is does that make sense
physically i mean
why isn't this dark matter between the
earth and the moon
and if we sprinkled it there we're upset
completely
newton and einstein both of them both of
them would be wrong and monde the uh
modified newtonian uh that
which is a maelstrom invented so it
would have
upset all the equations nothing would
work if we sprinkled
each grain of these each one of these
grains of dark matter
dark kilograms as i call them and they
weigh tons
and then conveniently invisible you know
that sort of thing so yeah that's magic
all that is magic holographic universe
uh
just nonsense that string theory needs
big bang uh creationism means that
the universe started from nothing matter
was created out of nothing
and you know i just want to know the
mechanism that's as soon as you explain
the mechanism
god will be listening together with me
because not even god can do that okay
nebular hypothesis again um
it's okay for the sun i have no problem
with the sun what's the nebula
uh it means that there's this cloud of
let me put ourselves in there
for a second it's this cloud of gas
right
gas and dust and matter etc probably
spat out by
a supernova or a nova that happened
before that okay so it sprinkles all
this gas
all this uh matter in a region of the
space you could say or versus other
matter
radial areas and what happens it begins
to spin there's so much
gas so much matter that begins to spin
and just like a skater you know pulling
his arms
inwards uh the this uh
mass of um of gas and
particles rotates and comes together
gravitationally also and forms what
eventually is going to be the sun
all this mass all this matter condenses
essentially and at some point
gravitation takes becomes stronger and
stronger and stronger until
finally it ignites and turns into a star
no problem there
that mechanism is not i cannot
imagine how the earth came out of that
mechanism
okay in other words what you have these
little uh
gas clouds supposedly orbiting the sun
i don't know why they didn't fall into
the sun but that's what they claim all
the way to pluto right all these
uh eight nine planets depending on what
version of pluto you accept whether it's
a planet or whatever
but all these nine planets they say were
clouds of dust
and gas that condensed locally also
through a nebular hypothesis so this the
tabular hypothesis pertains to the
creation
of solar bodies of the planet
essentially the planets
so they're saying this is you're saying
it couldn't have been
all this dust that turned into little
balls here and there right
uh because for example take a
a little uh object tiny object like
ceres
which is uh the um what is it the um
uh the biggest asteroid we got out there
and
it's round completely around it's a
little marble compared to
you know the earth or the moon or
whatever it's a it's a tiny
object it's round it's a round object
and uh
mimas which is one of the moons uh out
there
is is even smaller and it's perfectly
round
or quite round and you say how did that
little guy
you know condense into this little
marble because the sun we can all
understand we said well all that mass
all that gravity sure
but how do you explain the little marble
well but by the nature of gravity
wouldn't all of them be
round because they all essentially like
it'd be weird if it was a cube
okay first uh you could say that but
then
you got a different uh second problem
that you got to add to that which is
differentiation
means that there's all these uh
celestial objects
are layered there there's different
layers of it like the earth has all
these different layers
the heavier ones in general are towards
the center the lighter ones
are towards the periphery yeah
and in fact uh we have gases like oxygen
and nitrogen
we breathe it why because it's on the
periphery hopefully it's not the other
way around have the gases on the inside
of the earth and the iron
we'd be breathing iron on the outside
that's the other way around it's the
lighter ones on the outside
what is that you're looking at a star
that's the the earth used to be a star
because that's how it
that's why it's layered and that's why
it's also round
you you cannot produce that kind of
roundness unless you have this
gravitational collapse
that happened in the same way it
happened to the sun
in other words it was a nebular
hypothesis gazillions of years ago
not 14 billion like relativity says
we're talking about trillions of years
and uh our
earth was a star that turned into what
is known as a black
dwarf okay black dwarves are uh stars
that have already exploded and
they reached the end of their lives and
turned into this uh
solid thing called the earth beautiful
earth blue earth with
air and all that good stuff around it
did you ever get into why some turn into
gaseous planets like uh neptune or
whatever
and some turn into rocky ones well i
think uh
in the case of uh jupiter and saturn
neptune and uranus they did not have
enough mass to ignite
so they are stars that came in
trying to try to come into being but
never made it but an important point
there
is that if you look at the satellites
that go around jupiter that go around
uh saturn they're rocky planets
and you say we got a problem because if
the nebular hypothesis
four planets is correct why did these
guys
end up with i mean jupiter is just a gas
ball okay
but it's surrounded by little
tiny moons that are all solid
and so how do you explain that because
they should all
if they were all at the same radius from
the earth
from sorry from the sun they should all
be gas balls or whatever
you know or they should all be your
rocky planets and then we have
jupiter which is a gas ball and it's
surrounded by little rocky
uh moons satellites i like that question
how do you get a new star
you get a new star by uh the rotation of
gases again the sun
let me let me give you this nebular the
nebular hypothesis is okay for the sun i
have no problem with the nebular
hypothesis for the sun
and even for the earth billions of years
ago
but when but the earth was a captured
dwarf plant a dwarf star or a little
planet
it was already a planet and the last guy
to appear in the solar system was the
sun
that simply got all these uh existing
planets and began to twirl them around
well let's put it this way if the sun
were to explode and finish its cycle
so we have now the solar system without
a solar without a sun
would there ever be another sun in that
solar system again would there be
another ignition
and another star in that in our solar
system
well you got to look at the region of
space
yeah because in other words you got to
look at the let's let's look at the
distances from other star system in the
region yeah
that region if it explodes like if the
sun explodes
it's going to leave behind an iron ball
yeah and who knows what happens to the
earth the jupiter all that gets
washed away to some other part of the
you know maybe to all the way to
the um what is it to uh alpha centauri
for all they take a vacation
yeah they go out of the solar system and
what it would leave behind would be
a little uh uh little
uh uh an iron ball which is what the sun
would be left at the
at the end of its life and someday that
would be captured by
some other stars that drifts through
space and at some point
it becomes maybe a planet a black dwarf
of some other solar system
that's the life that that the sun can
expect to have
in its uh late uh late late late
late he's an old man yeah okay let's
continue here
uh well we'll then later look at the
questions and answer them let's let's
just finish up here
uh anyways uh dark energy it's the
energy
necessary to push all the galaxies away
from each other
okay which is what they're saying
happened after the big bang all the
galaxies were formed eventually
first matter then it condensed into
planets and stars and eventually into
galaxies and then all these galaxy
everything is running away from each
other
and you say well why doesn't gravity
pull all this stuff back together
and so for that they had to invent this
invisible spirit called
dark energy which is pushing all this
out that's the
driver of the expansion of the universe
that's what they're saying
pushing it out from the center yeah from
a big bang from uh
what is it uh ground zero it's still
exploding or what yeah
it's still exploding but they say it's
not an explosion but it is
it's a hammer yeah i don't know they
they keep saying contradict themselves
they say it's a
there was a big bang which sounds about
right like
but then they said it wasn't a hand grin
it wasn't a big bang it's just a slow
push
and that's because they can't explain
what happened on uh frame number one
of that film they always start to frame
number two yeah
okay that's part of the problem okay uh
we also covered a few people with
mathematical physics
on her role okay and we went through
brian green michio kaku
uh tyson nye uh carl sagan just touched
upon some of these guys paul davies
uh jim malcoly i put him separately
because
we covered quite a bit of his material
uh
partly because he's backed by the bbc
and he made a
long series of videos with him he's also
written a couple books
so i treated him a little specially
compared to the others
he did a little more work uh
pushing mathematical physics and some of
these others
okay atheism we covered that a couple
times it's the religion of mathematics
why uh because atheism has to do with
belief
we're still doing philosophy or not name
philosophy we're doing religions
it's religion it's not philosophy
philosophy would be you know
explaining a a purpose a reason
that's not what atheism does atheism
says look i don't believe in god
oh you don't believe in god okay you
don't believe in the existence of god
you know
and again it's belief in existence
existence they never defined it and then
you can't use the word belief where the
word exists
okay you don't believe that this chair
exists the chair exists whether you
believe or not
well you could say you could talk about
belief of existence couldn't you
could you give me an example like i
believe
you believe there's a washing machine
in over there but i can't see it it's
just a belief thing
yeah but you haven't explained the
purpose or
or see the issue is the issue is that
science is about explaining you got to
have that word explained in there
otherwise you know what's the purpose of
science but if
there's an explanation there's a
question
you can't explain something without a
quote what's the question that you're
explaining or what's the
what's the well yeah i mean that's the
context in other words you you have to
explain a purpose for something
and one of the issues there an important
issue is uh people say well
um why why is there something rather
than nothing
when you ask that question you're
already implying god
because you're implying that god or an
intelligence or whatever out there
already had a purpose a reason for
creating the universe
so whenever you ask why is there
something rather than nothing it's an
irrational question
because you're you're you're putting in
a physical context
well you're putting in a physical
contest in the context of physics
you're putting a question of philosophy
or
you know it's they're mixed you're
you're trying to say well
why is there matter the problem but
you're saying there was a purpose
for someone to create matter that's what
you're saying that's what's in your
rational question there's a wrong
there's a i want to say wrong assumption
but yeah there's a wrong assumption that
goes with the question
when you ask why is there something
instead of nothing it's like
you're already implying that there was a
purpose for there being something
right right and and what is purpose
means god
you're already implying god when you say
that question people don't even realize
that
uh but you're implying an intelligence
which is what we
usually identify with god some
intelligence a watchmaker out there that
said
uh i'm going to create a watch well why
are you creating a watch god
and i'm creating a watch because and
what comes after that
is irrelevant because you already answer
the question that
there is a god and you must believe in
him
because he had a purpose for it for us
or for the world or for the universe
okay okay uh finishing up here let's
continue
um touched upon some of the rising stars
these are the new generation of people
some of them you know
i just went and got probably
some of the most uh noticeable people on
the internet
i missed a couple there dr dave was one
of the guys that i missed there but
i i covered him one day as well and
lately i've been doing the nobles
why people won nobel prizes you know
we need to know what all these people
invented or discovered
what they did for humanity because
that's what the supposedly noble created
a prize for
those who help humanity the most in the
last year or whatever
and finally obviously again the issue of
extinction
it always comes back yeah we always have
that extinction issue
it never leaves us because i suspect
that
we're not going to make it past the 21st
century
and because
i don't think the economy of man man's
artificial economy
uh can grow forever and part of that is
that we can't reproduce
forever uh the curve of the reproduction
curve
since 1963 has gone you know has tapered
off it's uh
become asymptotic it approaches the
asymptote
and when we reach that zenith at
maximum point that's called zero
population growth we do not
increase any further than that meaning
that now we have a problem with what
with demand
because demand is a function of
population ultimately it's a function of
population
and so you don't have an increasing
population demanding more products
the companies don't sell so they have to
lay off
and when you lay off those people have
to make
a living somehow and what happens is
usually they cling to the government
more and more and more of them you know
until finally the whole system collapses
so that's one of the issues that's going
in the background
there are more more issues involved with
the extinction with the economics of man
but the point is that i'm saying that
economics is going to crash
because it crashes meaning that money is
no more
trade is no more you don't pray because
there's nothing to trade
the uh medium of exchange
the currency that we use is no more so
now you have no
way of making a profit so there's no
reason for you to go out there and sell
vacuum cleaners or whatever because
whatever they give you you can't use
anyway so what are they going to give
you paper for a vacuum cleaner or
whatever you
you're selling so trade is no more and
because of that
the whole system collapses and if the
whole system collapses maybe there's no
big deal the big deal is that
the people who produce food now have no
reason to produce it or distribute it to
the cities
and that's when we have a problem
because the only reason
we stay alive the only reason uh we live
one more day is because we eat
it's food uh besides breathing and
drinking right but
uh food everything else is expendable
yeah even sex not for me but for other
people
[Laughter]
is expendable you don't need computers
you don't need cars you don't need
airplanes you don't need
houses you don't need any of that what
you do absolutely need is food to live
one more day
okay and uh if right now we're producing
the food ourselves and we produce it for
what
for money for gain for uh
pecuniary reasons once that's over
no one produces food for the rest of us
and people say well i'll produce my own
food
well that's it well that's one issue but
the other issue is
city boys have problem producing food
but that's one issue that's
probably an issue you may be able to
solve what you won't be able to solve is
defense
right now defense consists of the legal
system
military police all these things they
vanish
there is no government and so there's no
one to protect you
okay and you say well a new mafia will
arise you know al capone
and his boys they take over some uh
group
some gang no because
food is the only thing that's going to
be important and again cannot stay
together unless they have food
and they can go in there and rob but
then you know they're going to fight
amongst themselves as well there's no
way
there's absolutely no way that anyone
will form an army
not anymore armies were okay in the old
days when we created them because
there was a a in a
what is it a um
an extensive farming uh that maintained
that army
everyone was in the farm right everybody
was into farming and so uh
some people donated people to the army
they donated their
their sons and daughters not daughters
but sons
they became soldiers but there was an uh
what do you want to say
a foundation a big an enormous
foundation of farming that maintained
those armies
that won't be the case so right now we
have very few
people producing food for everybody in
the world so it's the other way around
now it's not an extensive
uh population producing food now it's a
very very
tiny population one percent around one
percent
in advanced nations developed nations
maintains the rest
and so we have a problem we have a
problem because uh
once that collapses uh then
there's no reason to produce food or
distribute it to the cities
because there's no uh no more reasons
for it to uh
exist anymore uh the distribution system
our economic system
okay uh and what else okay well that's
that's essentially it
uh so let me go into the questions and
comments and we had some from last week
so let me go with those first
and then we'll go through the list of
people who are here today we'll try to
answer those as well
okay we start out with what we start out
with this uh
which is what i put the other day which
is mass
okay we have the same astronaut at two
locations with respect to the earth we
weigh them
at a higher altitude and a lower
altitude
i already gave one of the answers to one
of those questions
uh they do have a different a
weight okay and the one on the bottom
weighs more than the guy in the top and
the question
you got to answer is why what causes
the one on the bottom to weigh more than
the one on the top i mean it's common
knowledge that
people in higher the objects and higher
like in a mountain weigh
less if i were on a mountain i would
weigh less than if our on ground
yeah and uh and we know this uh from um
the uh notion of uh field
what is a field it's a value at each
point around an object whether it's
electrical magnetic or
gravitational it's a value a set of
values around an
object it's a radial phenomenon as you
go farther and farther away in all those
cases
the the strength is weaker the question
is why
we need to answer why the what's what's
the physical cause
and uh okay so we don't have an answer
but some people
gave mass and gravity a shot
and here's one fellow and he says the
following he says
i can read this thing says weight is a
measure we use
it to calculate things such as density
mass is derived from the periodic table
of elements
well great but uh i need to know what
mass is we need we need an answer
we need a definition for the word mass
and we don't have one there okay
we need a physical interpretation
because we need to explain what is the
mechanism that's making the lower
astronaut heavier
than the higher astronaut even though
they're the same exact asteroids
and it would help if we start by
defining mass and right now nobody can
tell me the difference between mass and
weight
everybody goes to high school or that
goes to high school learns that mass is
the quantity of matter
and we had already mr wheeler and mr
taylor they wrote a book these guys
are head honchos they die one wheeler
died already but
a couple years ago but they said um
mass is not the quantity of matter okay
and i explained the other day that
uh you know if you accelerate a particle
which is what they do in those
accelerators or what they think they're
doing
uh they say it gains more mass so
obviously it's not the quantity of
matter
because then you would say what did the
particle increase
the amount of matter as it went by or
are we talking about
how much it presses down on the on the
scale which is weight
so again there is no difference between
mass and weight because everything we've
done on earth
for the last 500 years we've always used
weight we never
never counted atoms we never counted
quantity of matter
okay we just assume that weight is a
measure of the quantity of matter
okay that's all we have and if you
accelerate the elephant he weighs more
on the scale no kidding and it's not the
same thing for the elephant to stand on
the
scale than to drop them on the scale and
so that's
that's what they do with mass okay and
the fellow continues as
if trying to ask what is mass made of
i'm going to go with nikola tesla
walter russell nassim how to mine
eric dollar david lapoint and how many
mourns in one sentence yeah there we
agree how many mourns in one sentence
now you got to define what mass is and
if mass is a concept then
you cannot ask what is mass made up
love is not made of anything all
concepts are not made of anything
intelligence is not made of anything
data is not made of anything
uh so you can't say that mass is made of
something so that is not the question
the question is
please define the word mass and show how
it is different than weight
and uh show me an example because
we don't have an example uh what we do
is uh
use analogies and say for example that
if we take uh the grand kilo in
france which was the standard of the
kilo until
uh the year 2000 i lost a few atoms i
know and
you take that to the north pole it's
going to weigh it differently
and you say well the weight changed but
not its mass well it did because the way
we determine
its mass is by weighing so yeah it must
change also i mean it'd be kind of hard
if we counted atoms yeah right they can
take a long time and and like wheeler
says you can't count atoms
because which atom are you going to
count the uh uranium atom the
hydrogen atom uranium has 92
protons it's like 92 hydrogen atoms more
or less okay
not to mention the neutrons it has okay
so yeah
you can't do it so yeah you got you got
to define what mass is
and no it's not what mass is made of
because concepts are not made of
anything okay okay let's get back in
here
uh one file says
uh he says uh i'm not mocking you in any
way
oh go ahead i have no problem with
people mocking me i mean i've received
mockings
and mocking birds for the last 20 years
so join the cloud crowd don't worry
about
offending me your job is to offend me
okay and i don't take offense very
easily
among other things that's not the only
job
yeah so no no you can cuss my mother on
my channel
as long as youtube allows it i don't
care i mean i don't care
really you don't now he might care i
know
i do it too i don't care
okay another since your cosmos is finite
absolutely not i don't know where you
got that
uh cosmos equal universe equals matter
and space
meaning it's a concept and concepts are
neither finite nor infinite okay
uh love my love is infinite but you know
i mean
you know it's i guess it means the
matter in the space yeah he
probably did yes i wonder how the
tension between all the ropes in the
cosmos remains main
remains maintained uh well i'm just
going to give you two answers here one
is that
um the velocity of light is a constant
under the rope model why because it's
the inverse relation between frequency
and wavelength
link length okay so c
equals uh frequency times wavelength is
the equation of a rope
okay and you have it here um
you know the more we torque this the
more the more
links you have and the shorter each link
frequency
wavelength we got it now you untorque it
you get fewer links each link is longer
frequency
times weight we got it okay so the
velocity of light is a function of those
two that is the equation of a row
there's no other
entity we can imagine that can uh
mimic or simulate that equation what do
you mean by tension is not a force
okay yeah so then if the velocity of
light
is the same between any two atoms
because the rope only changes
uh frequency for wavelength and vice
versa
then what happens if the velocity relate
is a constant that is the
tension in the universe and so
the question here is and let's go with
the third one he says tension
uh should have done its work and pulled
all the masses meaning
you know like uh newton said you know
why doesn't all this
lump into one place and newton had a
good answer for that
and it was the notion of galaxy and
that's that you know you have all these
galaxies
out there and they're all doing their
own thing that's one issue
you know they're all like centers of
gravity they're too far apart from each
other to
first they're too far apart but then you
have all these are rotating and
moving in different directions and this
is what creates the universal tension on
the rope we don't even know if all the
matter
that is in existence rotates as a whole
or in different directions so that
maintains the tension on the rope
and centrifugal force it's centrifugal
uh in a sense you know um
i think it's just rotation in different
directions that maintains the tension on
the rope
and one of the issues there is maybe we
have tension here but maybe on the other
side of the universe
there's a little slack coming in and
then it goes out you know i think
there's all these motions going on
and that maintains uh the tension on the
rope i mean i imagine it like
a bubble of water like if you had a
bubble of water in space
it's just kind of moving doing its own
thing where the the edges of it are
going in and out
like constant motion the edges of the
bubble you mean yeah
yeah yeah that's how i imagine the edges
of the of the matter in the universe
yeah i think the space i think first the
fact that we have all these uh
islands known as galaxies that's one
issue and the other one is
that the whole the whole universe in
other words the matter
of the universe is rotating in different
directions
and maybe one is going out while the
other one's coming in you know i think
you have all these motions and that
keeps the tension on the rope i think
all around it's the motion of the
galaxies that maintain the perpetual
motion that we have
of matter okay and so he says tension
should have done its work and pulled all
the masses
well the problem is the word tension
tension does not pull
tension and pull uh do not go together
except in mathematical physics they
think tension is a force
tension is not a force because no one
wins the tug of war
force is the opposite force someone wins
the tug of war whether pushing or
pulling
there is a motion in one direction or
the other tension
no motion okay it's uh think of tension
i always like to
think of tension as a stick made of a
single piece
you know it doesn't shrink and doesn't
get longer because it's made out of a
single piece that's tension
essentially it's a way of visualizing
tension
just a stick made of a single piece hey
you're back
okay another issue we had a problem with
squares apparently uh people have
problems with squares yeah let's find
out
uh if i can get this somewhere yeah yeah
you got a problem with squares
yeah because because people will say a
square is not an object now i'm saying
yeah i didn't see it's got shape and
that's the definition
of your definition okay then people have
the option to
redefine it and defend their definition
if you don't like the definition that
which has shape
your job is to define it people don't
never define it they just want to argue
that
no no a square is not an object no
that's an ordinary speech
backed up by a lot of questions here
yeah yeah i know we'll get to them
uh he says define mathematically perfect
okay if it's defined it's not an object
let's see what
he defined he says square four
perpendicular
lines that end at the next okay so i put
these uh
four lines two dimensional lines okay
because uh there is no
object called that's zero dimension or
one dimensional right
so we had uh four squares there or two
four elongated uh
rectangles okay and
that's not a square what that or or a
physical left that's four
different physical objects that's a
concept okay so
no uh if you can define it uh it's a
concept and
a square is not what you see there
square is what i showed there in red
which is a single piece okay and it's uh
got shape because it's got some contour
of some kind
so um you know a square is an object by
definition
pursuant to the definition you don't
like the definition no problem
uh give me your definition and be be
prepared to defend it with sword and
shield because i'm gonna attack you
okay uh another issue
uh foul says
explain so a blind man without eyes can
understand what you're talking about
okay helen keller she was blind uh she
was deaf also
more or less stuff i think uh and mute
she could not speak
and uh and sullivan made uh miracles out
of her
uh and she did it by she learned a lot
by touching with her fingers okay she
not only have to you gotta work out what
you got yeah yeah so
unfortunately she was not quadriplegic
as well
uh but the issue is that it's an
irrelevant issue uh you have to define
what an object is talking about
well because uh he says uh how do you
explain a square
the issue was explain a square yeah or
how do you explain it to a blind man
because he's never seen a square
i don't care if the blind man or the
dead man understand me
when i die a square remains a square it
remains with shape
by definition it's an object so so
you gotta you gotta define the word
object you can't just keep talking
around the subject you gotta define the
word object
you gotta know what an object is
especially for the purposes of physics
why because the golden rule says the
golden uh
uh principle you can't do physics
without an object what would there be to
study
if we had no objects what would there be
to analyze what would be moving what
what phenomenon would be happening i
guess the problem that happens if you
don't define object is you end up with
weird theories of things popping in and
out of voice that aren't there
you mean you started from the vacuum
yeah you start inventing things that
the things don't do yeah yeah yeah
and you start moving concepts around you
call them you call them objects but
they're not objects what they are
you call them particles and you say well
you're talking about a little speck of
dust oh no no it's a number it's an
amount
oh it's a number then we're not talking
about shape
so yeah they had to they never defined
the word object and that's they skipped
that
and that was an important step okay
another
question comment here uh yes
oh yeah a lot of people oh man we're
stuck on squares we're in for the long
haul
jesus a square is a two-dimensional
representation well i don't know what a
representation is all i can tell you is
all objects only objects have dimensions
so if it's two-dimensional whatever
two-dimension is it's not a
representation it's an object
i guess people have the problem that
defining a square is an object because
people always think of objects as that
which you can see or touch
right a thing that they they're talking
about existence they're talking about
location
exactly that's the problem and that's
the notion of ordinary speech we say the
table is an object because you can see
and touch it
you're saying there are objects that
don't exist not uh
first that don't exist second that we
can imagine i can imagine a table that
one doesn't exist
uh geometry the two-dimensional plane
geometry at least
uh you know it's just imaginary and that
means you can visualize you can draw it
there's a shape there but it doesn't
exist what exists is the pen
in the paper and the ink or the chalk or
whatever
maybe the imagination is what kind of
messed it all up because if we didn't
have imagination then there would only
be things that
are and that's where people get confused
they think that because it's imaginary
it's a concept
no if it has shape it's an object
even if it's an imaginary shape is there
a reason to keep that
definition so rigid yeah it is because
it's the
the malleability of
that definition the fact that we've uh
made it
anything that's imaginary we say well
that's a concept no no
that's an ordinary speech in physics you
cannot have that definition
partly because you know usually c touch
which is what we usually identify with
objects um
that that definition requires a second
object
only another object can do the seeing
and the touching you need two objects to
define one
you need a right so yeah and it's an
irrational besides that you know it's
also an opinion you know in many
cases you know did did the asteroid
really touch the moon
you know through all of these uh we're
almost there
okay let's keep going here otherwise
we'll spend the whole night
hey we're on the cubes
okay so here it goes uh cube the only
shapes we consider is objects dictionary
definition of object our
third third dimensional cube is a third
dimensional representation again
representation right of a fourth
dimensional hypercube a
tesseract in all other higher dimensions
well there are no higher dimensions
exactly higher yeah
except when you drink too much then you
have higher dimensions i i know i've
been there
not once uh but no no higher dimension
but let's uh look at the tesseract real
quick which
we need to look at that because people
think a tesseract
or hypercube is a physical object
supposedly
it is but it ain't uh because they
define it as a four-dimensional object
now it's a three-dimensional object
actually moving through time that's what
i want to show here
the first issue here is that you know
the dictionary definition
requires a second object which is c
touch
so again until you define the word
object you have no case you need to
define the word object you can't say
well this is what we call object uh
normally we don't care what it's
normally we're saying what it is
for the purposes of physics for the
purposes of science
it has to be a scientific definition
which means
one that you can use consistently you
cannot use the seed touch criterion
or criteria in in a consistent way
because it requires a second object
among other reasons and a lot of it is
opinion but here let me show you
something here's a tesseract and you can
see it's moving
around okay and you say okay i
understand that it's a
it's a three-dimensional object that's
moving in
moving in space or rotating or whatever
like jello
yeah but see let me tell you the problem
there the problem there is that the
inside cube the nested cube the one
that's on the inside
uh is growing and becomes the one on the
on the outside that's what a hypercube
is a small cube that's becoming bigger
in all directions
okay so what you see there those corners
that's the axis of time a number line
and the problem here is that they're
moving time they're moving motion itself
that's what it is so here here let me
show you piece by piece what they're
doing
they're saying that a cube that grows
over time
is a tesseract that's what it is you
have this movie that turns into a
photograph
what you have a little cube that goes
bigger bigger and bigger
because that's what it is the inside
cube is growing in all directions
becoming the tesseract they're saying
the object the the picture that we're
going to show you is the process
yeah because you're getting bigger
because it's through time yeah the
fourth dimension according to
this time you can't have a picture with
time right
and what they're doing then is rotating
time
right because see what they're rotating
here
is is the height the entire hype per
cube
see so what they're doing here is
rotating time you see there
see what's happening there they're
rotating time itself they're rotating
motion
because the little cube is becoming
bigger at the same time that the whole
thing is rotating through space
and they're saying oh the tesseract the
four-dimensional tesseract
is rotating now that's irrational
because you're rotating time
i mean wouldn't all objects be
four-dimensional according to
i mean if you made time uh dimension
yeah
aren't all objects four-dimensional what
do they do that's what i'm saying
why do they why do they need the test
right we don't need it i mentioned
because as i'm three-dimensional moving
through time i'm for the i'm a
four-dimensional object everybody is a
four
everything in the universe is four
dimensional according to them
because they're they're talking about an
object moving through time or
as they say what it is is uh
you have an object in motion and the
worst part is when you
move when you have that movie and you
rotate the movie the entire movie
including time
and motion that's what ours that's what
a tesseract is it's a rotating
time that's what they're doing
so yeah it's totally irrational uh
mathematically you can treat it any way
you want because it's
you know mathematics is all abstract you
can do whatever you want there you just
put a
a variable and say x equals that you
move x no problem
but you can't turn that into physics and
that's why these people cannot imagine
say well the fourth dimension is
unimaginable
no kidding yeah everything is
three-dimensional out there okay
that exists that's part of the notion of
existence you know
if it has location it has to be
three-dimensional
uh if we didn't have the background of
the visible light spectrum we wouldn't
know what light was would we
well again you got to define the word
object we we got to know what
what that what is that word what
is an object and no no in knowledge uh
that's religion you know knowing uh has
no
place in uh the definition of object
there's no provision for knowledge
in in objects or existence for that
matter neither one
it's done only with assumptions it's
done with definitions
you define and then uh existence uh
you define it and then if the you say
the table
exists well let's look at the definition
what does word exist mean
it means a physical object that has
location that's what you just said
that's what you meant when you said the
table exists or the chair exists
oh and and the one that doesn't exist
maybe the one i'm imagining that one
doesn't exist why because
it's an object but it lacks location and
if it lacks location it doesn't exist by
definition not because i believe or no
so knowledge plays no part in all this
okay especially in the word exist
or the word object no provision for
knowledge
or for belief in the word exist
okay last couple ones here uh on
superman we had a couple issues there
one guy says is it drawing an object
i mean if you remove the paper and ink
there isn't a superman
left behind but i can visualize superman
in my head
as an object is that imagination
okay the only comment i want to say on
that i mentioned this in the past but
let's just show this okay a circle is
not a drawing
okay or a partial drawing like you know
half half a circle
circle what you see on the right a
finished product that's a circle
okay not the one that i'm drawing so
drawing superman uh just
want to make sure that you know if if i
don't finish uh superman or the
or the statue of superman well that's
not super not until i finish
it okay it's gotta be a finished product
then i can say that's superman if he's
missing his legs well that's
a different kind of superman you know
circle is
a finished product you you have to
finish it okay so drawing
is a verb okay and just let's keep that
in mind
drawing the the motion of drawing
something
is not the object so when i say
sometimes i say that i say that an
object is that which you can draw or
that you can point to
okay those are just to get you into the
habit of thinking that
we're talking about shapes okay but the
drawing
is not it's not the opposite yeah the
process of drawing is not
or sculpting or whatever is not the
object and last question here
again superman and what is it
we have this foul says uh none of the
imaginary phantoms you come up with
uh superman halos are not objects well
you gotta define what an object is
you can't say it's not you got to say
what it is well again they're talking
about objects in the sense of existence
yeah yeah but he's got to be
i need a definition yeah i'm sorry i
need to tell you about the notion that
everyone comes that
object with is things that are things
that are in
reality that's one issue but the other
one is they skirt the issue because they
don't want to define a word because they
can't define it
yeah or they go with the definition the
dictionary by default
which is an irrational definition that
we cannot use in physics
and that's why they don't define it
because as soon as they define it's easy
to tear apart
especially because it usually involves
two objects c touch involves two objects
and that has to do with existence and
not with object
and when people never realized that uh
david hume
uh emmanuel kant they both had that
problem they couldn't distinguish
between existence
and object okay and last issue there if
so i came up with a 3d box
drawn on a paper and can draw a fly on
it
tell me which side it is on irrelevant
there you have a fly
on a box uh okay and
okay so what's the issue i mean we need
to define the word object
just define the word object and then uh
whatever follows from
follows from that definition and while
you're at it do you find the word exist
okay
okay let's open the flora for questions
what questions do we have uh
sir crap ton of questions here
whoa okay let's start at the beginning
let's go here how do ropes create
pull or tension though how do they
create well they don't create
it's that's like saying that's like
saying
god created motion or god created the
universe or god created matter
you don't create motion is already there
motion
you can't say that motion started
because that's irrational that would
require an outside
force of some kind to get the things the
ball rolling yeah but when you're
talking when you're
in there uh object by the way you know
you
you can't imagine how matter came into
being and you cannot
imagine how motion started or came into
being
okay but earlier you said that tension
was like a stick
yeah so assuming you had three atoms
each attached with a stick how is their
gravity no
how's their pull
oh i see uh well again you have uh
two against one um
yeah i got that yeah it's an unfair
fight two versus one
uh in a way yeah i've got that in the
book because i've got a good example of
that
of how um how if if you have only two
objects in the universe two atoms
and you know you can't create gravity
the only way you can create gravity
is by aggregation remember gravity is
not a pull
for it it's not pull what it is is
aggregation you have
more over here and fewer over here okay
and so you have fewer atoms here
many atoms over here and and what
happens is
uh one uh object drifts
towards another and as it comes closer
the ropes fan out
okay so so yeah you need if you have
three atoms
then you can produce gravity but you
cannot produce gravity for example with
two objects
they can rotate let's assume you could
rotate them you know that's a
remember max principle requires the
stars to pull on you but let's
assume let's get rid of all the stars
rotate with respect to what
yeah right yeah you wouldn't have but
let's assume you only had two atoms tied
by a rope and that's the only thing
swinging around in the universe and
let's assume it just swings around okay
one atom with respect to another let's
try to visualize that for a second
well at that moment all you have is
tension
you know there is no there is no gravity
gravity is a force but only in the sense
that as a an object approaches another
the ropes fan out
and it's the fanning out of the ropes
the fact that you have more and more
what we call
effective ropes uh operating between
those two objects
that creates that that notion we call
gravity
that pull force that we see in our macro
world
what happens to the thread rope slack as
objects approach each other
uh it's eaten up in other words remember
the atom
is made out of the same thread as the
rope
one thread goes through the center of
the atom the other one goes around
and as one object as one atom approaches
another atom
what happens the the rope it gets reeled
in and out the other end
it's like sliding a bead on the abacus
the bead
uh does not eat up
uh it reels in so so speak the wire on
the
abacus and in in that sense it's
it's uh the best analogy maybe i can lie
it just slides through
one one thread goes over which is the
one forming the
uh shell electron shell the other one
the one that goes through the center
which forms the proton star
it just slides through those two threads
and they just go out the other end
so so there it always maintains tension
because
remember the atom is also pumping and
vibrating there there are different
motions uh one of them is uh the moss
bar
effect which is uh when it when the atom
is stuck to a
lattice crystal lattice it doesn't
recoil
so there's different kinds of motions
and so
you got to look at all these motions
together as an atom moves vibration
expanding and contracting doing
its quantum jump and while doing that it
it
it there's no reason for it for the rope
to slack between them because the rope
is being pulled by every atom in the
universe
there's too much motion for there to be
slick and and the atom that
i'm sorry the rope itself is always
under tension the only thing that
changes
is frequency for wavelength in other
words the number of lengths
and the linked length that's all that
changes c equals
frequency times wavelength that equation
is the equation of rope and it's always
a constant
that is a measure of the tension on the
rope
everywhere in the universe saying love
does not exist as in
has no shape and location is fine but i
really don't like having no
counter statement to it if love doesn't
exist if concepts don't exist
what do they like love justice they
don't exist because they have no
location
yeah what what do we say to concepts
yeah remember in ordinary speech we say
love exists
intelligence exists data exists we say
that that's an ordinary speech because
we don't have to be careful with our
language
in physics physics especially science
but the branch of physics
you have to define these terms because
physics is not only the science
of objects but it's the science of
existence so you can't
say oh i'm going to use the same
definitions as i have in ordinary speech
you cannot bring that definition that
loose definition
saying oh love exists you can't bring
that into physics you can't
because then what do you mean now you've
got to define the word exists
okay and same with god if you're going
to say god exists or god doesn't even as
well what do you mean by that
what do you mean by god exists what do
you mean by god doesn't exist
and that's where you got to bring in the
the definition that you can use
consistently
and what i'm saying is first you need to
have an object that rules out all
concepts
so you cannot say that love or
intelligence exists
in physics okay in physics in science in
a way that you can use consistently
rationally okay scientifically
i mean i guess we're talking about like
a pattern you don't really see a pattern
exist
but what do we say instead well you
can't use the word
exist with concepts in physics in
ordinary speech you can use it you can
say but in science if we're talking
about philosophy for example yeah but
the philosophy is under science
so we do have to define or we have to
we're talking about concepts
we could be talking about concepts under
philosophy so you but you can't
but you can't really say but that's the
problem
that's it like when you say we've
noticed a pattern or we've discovered a
pattern
in the natural world for example
whatever it might be
yeah but when you say pattern when you
say pattern you're saying
you're talking about a behavior yeah and
we use the word pattern pattern is very
misleading because you know when i use
the cookie cutter i love the pattern
on the dough and so people relate those
are the words that fall
on both sides and they say a pattern i
like that word because it
it it unites philosophy
with physics on the one hand i mean
pattern you know a
like a pattern of behavior and on the
other i'm saying pattern like the
the same thing over and over the cookie
cutter or whatever
no we can't use words that are ambiguous
you can't use the word exist
in the context of concepts in physics
in uh philosophy again you don't need it
you don't need the word exist
what are you going to say as far as uh
like if you're trying to explain
something in philosophy why would you
say that
love exists in philosophy you're trying
to explain you're explaining
a phenomenon of a behavior but then you
would not need to say at
no point you would not need to say first
that
a heart represents love and second you
do not need to say that
love exists you do not need to say that
not not in
philosophy which is a branch of science
so concepts now they don't exist you
can't use the word exist with concepts
does bill's rope hypothesis explain how
complex
orbital shapes within atoms are formed
hydrogen atom orbital seems easy enough
this is two balls
but how can some atoms have different
shaped bubbles within bubbles
like i don't know a uranium atom there's
just bubbles on bubbles on both well
remember the simplest way you got to go
slowly
because you got to visualize the
simplest and then work your way to the
complex
you have two hydrogen atoms when they
come together they form the h2
molecule gas molecule why did they do
that because
the rope between them uh remember it
goes over
one thread goes over the top and the
other one goes through the center
and the atom slides through those two
ropes until it meets the other atom
that means the rope disintegrated
completely another disappeared
what happens when these two atoms touch
electron shell against the electron
shell or membrane against membrane
well they start screwing into each other
if
if they're both rotating in the same
direction
meaning meaning from one end you can see
both of them going clockwise
meaning from one end you see clockwise
if you go from the other end you see it
counterclockwise right
so if the electron shells are spinning
from one
point of view in the same direction they
screw into each other and they form the
h2 molecule
if they're both spinning in opposite
directions they
bounce against each other flatten out a
little bit and then they bounce away
they have no
chance of merging and forming the h2
molecule
so what happens the threads get coupled
one into another form that figure eight
which eventually is
a single oval and that's just for the h2
molecule
you can you can see you can see how that
can be extrapolated to other molecules
uh it's it's um it's even very hard to
draw
okay but i've got like iron iron uh has
um
what is it uh 2s uh 3p
um shape in other words it's got these
uh
p orbitals and what they are is
essentially what we've done there is um
blended several hydrogen atoms together
to form
what we call iron how was that done it
was done in the sun through
pressure in a star right through
pressure
but yeah what happens is uh the threads
have no problem in merging one into the
other
they blend because they're all made out
of the same
threads it's it's a single thread in the
universe
so it's it's like you know immediate
meets each other
one one membrane meets the another
another membrane
okay
[Music]
can you talk about touch is there a
scientific definition for the word touch
uh the definition is zero distance
zero distance but the problem with that
definition is that zero distance means
the two
objects have become one so we have
the your finger touch the table in
ordinary speech we say oh
my finger touched the table but in
science we can't say that because
if it touches means there's zero
distance there's no space between them
you can't have the surfaces
yeah there's no individual surfaces
the surfaces have become one the finger
has become part of the table
and so now you don't have two objects
you have a single object so we have a
problem with the word touch
the word touch like the word exists uh
people don't pay attention to those
things but they're very important
because people say well it touched my
two fingers touched
well have they become one do they and if
they become one for their services well
i mean if well hold it hold it this is
the point
here we have two fingers right we have
two we say the finger touched
in ordinary speech no problem we have no
problem with it the problem is when you
do
try to do physics scientifically okay
and you say well what do you mean by
touch
well touch is zero distance because if
there's space between them if i still
have space then they didn't touch
yeah but if they touch we mean that
there's zero
distance in other words there's no space
between these two fingers
meaning they became one object and you
need two objects to
touch but they that's how we defined but
they became one object
it depends on where you cut off an
object
in your mind because because when you're
talking about an object you're talking
about
you're kind of giving it an imaginary
shape like when you're talking about a
chair
i can solve it i can solve it for you
look two fingers right yeah
in in physics science right
uh we say they touched but they didn't
touch because there's space between them
right
how do we their space they're still yeah
because
there's still space between them because
what you have is electron shell against
electron challenge if they don't blend
they don't blend then they're two
separate there's still space between
a tiny little space with their space
between them
but this is the this is the solution let
me tell you what the solution is
the solution is the following two
objects become one
that's called two objects becoming one
is touch
right
[Laughter]
see we have a different definition than
we have in ordinary speech in ordinary
speech you say well you touch because
what two surfaces came in contact
no that's not touching physics because
there's still space between them if
they're two individual objects
the only way they can touch in physics
is they become one object
and as long as you accept that we have
no problem we have a small debate over
the word real
reason that which can be thought of
again that's ordinary speech
no no this is a definition an official
definition
that which can be thought of can that be
used for anything
is that a legit definition
no it's not uh it depends on what you
need it for i guess
well an ordinary speech yeah oh no no
but in physics you can't
be thought of what's the problem with
that like that which can be imagined
uh we no you mean for the word exists in
other words real
meaning exists i guess because real is a
synonym of exists so
use the word exist don't use the word
real because you get confused
you're saying uh if i think of something
it exists
is is that what fella is saying i guess
it depends on what the
what what explanation is being used for
i guess because you can't really just
have a definition
in a vacuum it's really definitions are
always for a purpose
right always you always you can't just
kind of define the word i don't know
love just just for the sake of it
you kind of have to define it in context
of a question you're trying to answer
well is there any that's the question is
there any point in defining the word
object if you're not going to use it for
anything
right that's the first one you you can't
and the other issue is again if if i
imagine something you say well it exists
because i can imagine it
well we're creating resistance every
second then you know everybody imagines
stuff you know so we got 8 billion
people creating
existence we're more powerful than god
here you know
you're creating existence i mean what's
the point of saying that
anything that i can imagine exists
because the definition of
exists is anything i can imagine well
what can you use that for yeah that's
the purpose of it depends on what the
explanation is yeah it's it's it's a
worthless definition
i i also have another question if matter
can't really be created or destroyed
does that mean that the
universe keeps going on forever doing
similar things
exactly there's no beginning to the
universe
but that creates a serious problem in
our minds it just blows your mind away
and that's when you need a psychiatrist
because what it means is there was never
a first
human being because before the earth
billions of years ago there was another
earth or similar
earth a similar planet like the earth
somewhere in the universe
and there were humans there in that in
that planet
and billions of years before that when
there was another planet and there were
humans there human-like forms
intelligence that developed there and
before that there were another
planet billions of years before that and
you keep going
and going and going and going because
there was never an
origin to the universe and but he's also
saying there's never going to be an end
there's no end to it not only is there
no beginning or end just like there's no
beginning to matter and there's no
beginning to
motion that's true and we have we it
just blows your mind away
because we're not used to that in
ordinary
everyday life we always think that a
baby is born
you know and we say okay that's the day
he was born that's when he started
and this is when he died this is the
beginning this is the end the
alpha and the omega we're used to that
so we're not used to
things which are eternal so when when
someone says look there was never a
first human being there was never a
first planet
there was never a first galaxy it's
always been there you say well
what do you mean how can that possibly
be
it's definitely trippy yeah it blows
your mind away
it does is gravity tension or pull i
guess we've
covered that yeah gravity gravity is
tension
at different locations but isn't it
created by tension
no there's no first of all i want to
make what's the difference between
pulling attention let's start this okay
pull someone wins the tug of war there
is force
equals mass times acceleration means
that acceleration means you change
location but there is
in intention there is no change in
location
position about gravity no no first let's
let's clarify
tension versus force gravity
is tension at different locations for
any
if you stop the the movie and you look
at
just one frame no motion no time
just one frame just a snapshot a picture
right
the the whole universe is frozen at that
point
what you see is the number of ropes you
count them and say okay there's
gazillion robes there's one billion
ropes
now you move the object closer to the
earth for example right
now you look at that frame you freeze
the universe you just look at that frame
now it's got one billion and one rope
well
but now you have one more rope but it's
not more rope it's more
active ropes more effective ropes yeah
more effective
very important yeah yeah so what we're
seeing is the
same number of rows except that they're
no longer on the same
axis and so you have tension
tension not force but tension at
different locations
okay and that creates the notion for us
called the force of gravity because what
we see
is the cup falling towards the floor
and what we're what we don't understand
or what is difficult to visualize
that which are really what you really
have is that cup of different locations
and what you have is
different tensions different number of
effective ropes
at different locations more and more
ropes
effective ropes uh acting at different
locations
as you get closer to the center of the
earth is it safe to say there's more
triangles essentially yeah the angle
changes
actually it changes the angles of the of
the ropes as well
you know there's two effects one is the
angle and the fact that they're
no longer on the same axis as they were
before and you can see this very easily
when you have two objects very far apart
uh you know if you take uh a hundred
guys
and you hold their ropes uh you know
every 100 people
with ropes one rope each person and you
have a hundred of them in your in your
hand right
the closer they approach the the more
the ropes fan out
yeah and if these people are infinity
you know where
mathematicians send you at infinity well
you see them all
you know almost on the same coaxial it's
like a single
rope you know they're all in front of
you they're not no longer to the sides
are atoms like knots pulling the ropes
around with them
are they more like beads on a string or
do they move in some other faction
fashion well they do move like
again like a beat on an abacus they do
move they slide along the rope that's
one issue but they're also knots
they're they're not uh yeah i think of
them as knots as well remember
it's a place where um
the ropes converge and one branches out
and forms the electron shell or membrane
and the other one goes in and forms a
proton star so they in that sense
they're not
you can also think of a neutron as knots
at least i do
uh not everybody agrees that uh watches
for the rope model
there are different opinions on this as
well different theories
uh my version is that the
neutron is a convergence of ropes and
the perimeter
of that neutron is
more or less where the electron shell
would be
on a hydrogen atom that's why the
neutron more or less
weighs as much as a hydrogen atom
if gravity is tension how do we get
attraction
why do larger objects win the tug of war
well because uh it's got more ropes more
atoms it doesn't have more ropes
they have the same amount of ropes no no
but i mean one it has more it has more
atoms
therefore therefore if you if you take
two objects here
here you have two objects okay two balls
okay
and this one's lighter this one's
heavier so this one's got more matter in
other words this one
has got more hydrogen atoms let's just
talk about let's call that the unit of
matter
so this one whether it's got uh carbon
or nitrogen or whatever it doesn't
matter
what we're saying is because this one
weighs more than this one this one's uh
made out of um sponginess right
uh this one doesn't weigh as much so
this one doesn't have as
many hydrogen atoms in it as this one
this one has more hydrogen atoms so
these two were in space
so if these two guys are in space this
one gonna win the tug of war
against this one in other words because
first this one's pulled by every atom in
the universe so is this one
so that's what what keeps them out there
you know with respect to all other atoms
but why does this one approach that one
more than this one approaches this one
moves that one in that direction as well
but this one moves uh in in this
direction
uh covers more ground okay why because
you know if you have an ant and an
elephant well hopefully the
ant falls towards the elephant not the
elephant towards the end poor little ant
then
the question is why okay
because this guy has more what we call
inertia
and what's the inertia inertia is a
measure of how much
how many atoms how many how much matter
it's made out of
you know it's got it weighs more on the
earth for example right you get the
elephant
you got the ant the guy that's going to
move is the ant not the elephant
okay so why because he's got more matter
and
all the ropes all the atoms that make up
the ant
are tied to all the atoms that make up
the elephant
but you know it's uh even though the ant
is also pulling
on the elephant like you know you're
pulling on the earth whenever the earth
pulls on you
but the earth has a lot more atoms and
so you fall
towards the earth not the earth so much
towards you it's actually a tricky
question because it implies something
else
if if the elephant and the ant were the
only two
objects assuming there's it doesn't
matter if they're single pieces are made
of many atoms
if you just had an elephant an ant no
other matter you wouldn't you couldn't
tell
if one is pulled to the you couldn't
tell if the ant is pulled to the
elephant the only reason
the only reason you could see that is
because you have all this other
matter in the universe with which to
compare it to you see
you're tired you're tied down yeah yeah
but the elephant is here and the
in the ant is here yeah with respect to
the rest of the universe if there was
nothing else there then these
two would just come together and you
wouldn't even see the elephant staying
there for example yeah and and that's
what it's like
it's it's a weird it's got to do it's
got to do with two things one
is with newton's bucket the fact that
you
tie a bucket to a string and uh full of
water
and you rotate it well the water goes up
up the uh
sides of the pail and you say what's
pulling it there
why does it stay level well it's all the
stars that are pulling on it and that's
known
as today is max principle the stars are
pulling on you
otherwise you know you wouldn't you you
wouldn't notice the difference between
the elephant and the ant
the the only reason is every you know
the elephant is anchored
by all the stars in the universe aside
from the earth you know
so there's no gravity in line stuck of
atoms i guess
we're talking about a stack of atoms if
you have a row of atoms there's no
gravity there
it with respect to the object that
you're measuring gravity against yeah
in other words if all the uh atoms are
lined up
then all you have is the last atom is
the only one pulling
on on one atom here well they're all and
all the over the ones that are in
between
that are on the same axis they're
irrelevant they're irrelevant like i
showed in the um
in the picture of the tug of war between
uh
andy and bob and then you have uh what's
his name uh
charlie he comes in he just holds the
rope you know
they don't feel him one guy's pulling on
the other guy
and charlie is irrelevant the only way
that charlie can become relevant the
only way he can
pull on both of them because either he
pulls
with bob or he pulls with andy but the
only way he can pull on both of them is
if he comes out of alignment he brings
the rope out of the line in fact i do it
with a
rubber band uh see right now
it's it's these two fingers but now my
son is going to pull that out of the
line
if you just hold the the no no just hold
it first uh just
no no yeah but you're pulling me down
see if he holds it i don't feel him at
all i'm still feeling my two fingers
but you pull it out of alignment now now
i feel him now i feel him
and you can do this at home always in
the presence of a
trained relativist okay he'll show you
that the only way you can
feel the force of pull is if he goes out
of alignment
let's talk about three atoms which is
one of my favorite situations
if you have three atoms in space no
other uh
three atoms objects yeah why
does one i mean they don't would they
all come together
no no no no uh again it's very difficult
because
again we've got matter all the stars etc
that are pulling on the three atoms but
another situation is
god comes in and wipes out all the atoms
in the universe only
he only created three atoms we have a
problem there because the only way
you're going to get
that tension is if they rotate
and rotate is only when you have uh
matter out there so it's a it's a
situation that you cannot really
reproduce you can try to
visualize it but you're also making a
lot of assumptions there
saying that you know you already have
max principle
working there that all the stars are
pulling on those three atoms
you can't do it with just three atoms
alone god would go crazy trying to
create just three atoms and having them
do something
all you can do is try to uh simulate it
and say look
what happens with three atoms and and
all i can tell you is the following
that if the all three atoms are on the
same
uh put your finger there in the sun if
they're on the same
axis i don't feel his hand at all the
only way i can feel it is if he goes out
of alignment then i can feel it
and that's what happens when you have a
row of atoms with respect to one atom at
the far end of another object
all those atoms are irrelevant the only
one that is relevant the one on the
on on the ends and the only way you can
get
uh to feel the other atoms is by
approaching
you know shortening the distance in
which case
uh now those atoms fall out of alignment
in other words they the
uh the ropes uh with respect to the
other object are
um acting independently yeah they're not
understanding
the fanning the fanning out if you have
a fanning out then
you have more and more of these guys not
on the same line so now all of a sudden
they're felt
yeah they're felt because suddenly this
one's acting
independently it's it's the same thing
as this the only way i can feel
you is if you go out of alignment then i
can feel that that finger
otherwise if he's just holding there you
don't feel
and and again do it at home take a
rubber band or a string
and just pull your hands you know one
against the other just tension
and you'll feel one hand with respect to
the other the only way you're going to
feel
the atoms in the center if they go out
of alignment
and that's what gravity is
got a lot of text here keep talking keep
talking
[Laughter]
talking about def definitions well the
thing the problem that i always
see with definitions it's hard for
people to get their head around
is when you have to define words to
explain something
you don't just define words in a vacuum
like here hippie smokes
is defining the word real from earlier
that which you can
that which you can imagine that which
you can think of but
in a vacuum that doesn't really give you
anything unless you're actually going to
use the word real
in a scientific well a lot of that has
to do with
uh preserving your religion because
people
there have these sometimes subconscious
but
uh they have this protection they they
have some beliefs
or some theories and they
feel that those theories are threatened
uh when a new definition comes in
and so that's there's a protectionist
issue there where people say well no i
like the definition of ordinary speech
that's the one i've always used the one
i'm
comfortable with because it protects
your religion
and you get a challenge is what uh
hasn't said uh in what is the 10th
century
he said uh the true scientist
begins by attacking everything he
believes
he begins there he's he he questions
he he acts as an enemy of everything he
believes
and that's what you should do so
accept the definition first the new
definition
and apply it to yourself and it's gonna
be uncomfortable
you're gonna you're gonna lose a lot of
uh you know a lot of your
ideas or beliefs and theories or
whatever
you know and it's challenging because
you're saying look i'm going to attack
my beliefs let's see i'm going to act as
my own devil's advocate can you work
into it
and the way you do it is by applying a
definition that is uncomfortable
you know and and they're not not that
many critical definitions
uh for the foundations of physics
there's i have like eight definitions
maybe 10 i don't remember now
but uh it's uh object exist location
distance there's like 10 of them and
those forms the foundations of physics
and the difference is that they don't
mean the same thing as in ordinary
speech
and i had to do that because those it's
the malleability
uh the the fact that you can mold them
that's what prevents us from
understanding how the universe works
and once you define those words at least
you can talk consistently and yeah that
that uh offends people because suddenly
their religion is threatened
they say oh hold it this affects my
religion yeah it does
and so you gotta apply it to yourself
you you gotta
whip yourself you know flog
make sure make sure you're comfortable
with your theories you know
there there's this this uh notion that
ubisoft brings up that it's
it kind of makes me think of back to the
topic of patterns when we're talking
about a pattern we're not talking about
something that
exists because it doesn't have location
but when you see
but philosophy treats talks a lot about
behaviors and patterns
and you can't really talk about a
pattern or a concept
such as love being existing
but what could you talk about like when
you notice a pattern in
in nature for example like extinction
for example
that's what that's happening then you're
talking about a
happening and you can't say that a
happening exists
yeah that's that's not that's but but
then what do you use but then what word
would you use
instead of exist well it is
remember that philosophy deals with
concepts first and then it deals with
reasons and
purposes the word exists does not fit
into any of those contexts
so you can't use the word exist in
philosophy but then what would you use
well you
use other words but i mean you can't use
the word exist because the word exists
is exclusive
of physics and in philosophy we
explain reasons and and purposes for
example why someone did
something right it could be a crazy guy
who killed people out there okay
why did he do it why did he commit
suicide why did he go to china
you know you ask a why question and it's
a why
refer not not like a cause or mechanism
but you're referring to
purpose and reason and what's the
purpose of using the word exist
in that context that's what you got to
come up with you got to come up with an
example where you where you can use the
word exist
in the context i'm trying to use the
word no no but i'm saying the
this is the challenge okay this is what
i'm throwing for those who have
out there this idea in their minds try
to apply the word exist
in the context of purpose and reason
come up with a come up with a that's why
we're trying to invent a new word
okay all i'm saying is if you can't do
it then you can't use the word exist in
that context
in philosophy philosophy is not the
science of existence
okay this begs the question why mother
nature prefers more pull than less
i guess we're talking about gravity i
don't know uh not clear and not clear
hey i know that guy
go up a little bit what do you say
is this talking to the people here uh
when he says
he means scientific yeah yeah we're not
using the word exist we're using the
word real
yeah but real that exists our synonyms
but he's saying they're not synonyms
because real
is that which you can imagine exists is
that which has location
no real is also that which has located
there is no he's changing the definition
yeah but then what's the context what's
the candidate again a pattern in
reality for example love love doesn't
exist that has no location it's just a
concept
but it's a pattern that we've observed
in philosophy yeah but you can say that
but you
when you say that love is real what
you're saying in a roundabout way is
love exists no
yes that's the thing we're using we have
to use a different uh word because we
can't use exist
right but uh we have to use a new word
what are you a behavior that we notice
this is my question the question is when
we say
in philosophy not in ordinary speech now
we're looking
at science science is divided into two
branches physics and philosophy
and under the philosophy branch we say
love is real let's assume that okay what
is the context
what do we really mean when we say love
is real we're talking about what you're
saying that exists no we're talking
about the pattern that we've observed
in human nature then why don't you say
it was the pattern i observed in nature
and saying love is real because love is
real means love exists
unless you define the word real yeah you
got it like we're talking about real
concepts versus unreal concepts i guess
because an unreal concept would be
things that we haven't observed in
nature
i assume yeah but again you gotta define
the word real
very precisely once we got that we know
what we're talking about
that which we can imagine uh
yeah but needs more more investigation
yeah
yeah you can uh the word real the word
is a synonym exists and both belong to
physics unless you define it
otherwise well it's like the word
rational which you separated from
logical
yeah which are synonyms in ordinary
speech yeah
to some degree they are they're not even
complete synonyms in ordinary speech but
uh
rational means uh again uh we refer
primarily to theories and the number one
there is that you can't move concepts if
you move concepts you're an irrational
individual
he says i'm too offensive with that so
we say
it's an irrational theory
i mean it's just more logical to talk
like that um going back to a really
earlier question how are new stars
formed we never really answered that
how is there a star form because we
talked about a star exploding turning
into an iron ball but how is a new star
ignited
oh no that's the nebular hypothesis i
have no problem
with it you have a uh a cloud of gas
and and debris atoms
iron whatever was spat out by a
supernova or anova
and you have this this cloud of gas and
this cloud of gas
begins to rotate why because again
gravity
gravity forces it to go into these uh
circles like like a galaxy more or less
or like a skater
so they begin to turn and gravity pulls
every one of those atoms towards the
center
once it gets there it forms this cloud
of
gas which we call a star or a protostar
and it eventually gravity pulls it
together
more and more until it becomes almost a
perfectly round sphere
and at some point because of that
pressure starts igniting
what does igniting mean it means that
now
it radiates in others the it has a high
frequency
the ropes are torqued to a high
extent okay so you have the
many links and short
links we call that high frequency and
you get into
such high frequency like x-rays
and gamma rays and that's what it
that's what comes out of those ropes and
that's that's the signal
those vibrations those torsions are what
we receive here on earth
we call that the sun okay but what i'm
saying is
when you compress that you have pressure
and that pressure inside the center of
the sun
forces that high uh frequency to shoot
out
to shoot out through every one of the
ropes
in the universe that's connected to that
sun to that star
so no problem with the nebular
hypothesis the only difference here
is that for planets a planet was
a star that was captured by a star like
our sun
so any other planet out there in the
universe
uh is just a and a dead sun
a dead star that's that which captures
the is our sun gonna turn into a rock
yeah our sun i guess it already is a
rock in the middle well i think there's
a
what needs to be studied a little more i
i haven't done
uh great research on that but you have
stars which are very big
you know antares and so on you know that
have
they're humongous and they're eventually
going to turn into supernovas others are
just going to be novas
so there's novas and supernovas our sun
is going to be a nova
not a supernova and uh so you get
different results from those
uh agglomerations of matter
which is what a star is can you do an
animation of what happens to a magnet's
threads when you spin them
i do have a i do have an animation in
fact
let's see maybe i can spinning magnets
seem to produce
some odd phenomena i'm curious about
what the threads are doing
let's see uh well here's a one let's see
if i can get it in here
give me a second here you know juggle
while you do that no no
give me a second
holy crap that's a lot of gifts oh yeah
we got a library yeah he's got a lot of
folders here
oh no it's over here thousands of
folders of gifts
made throughout the ages what were they
kangaroo god
gravity magnet one two and three
oh okay how many are in here
okay here you'll see uh whoa
who's the wrong guy let me get that
here's an animation gives you an uh a
feeling for it
okay you see the threads
during push and pull and
what you see here is if you turn it
sideways nothing changes you still have
red against
blue or north against south but when you
turn it 180 degrees now you have
push they push each other away okay look
at it one more time
you have red against blue and they're
going in the same direction they're
going clockwise in that case here you're
also going clockwise
and now you're going to have one of them
going counter-clockwise against
clockwise
and they push each other away the rope's
whipping yeah
they hit each other away slapping
high-fiving yeah
yeah essentially that's that's the
mechanism
and one of the problems people have and
this this has to be clarified because
this is where people have a problem with
this okay and it's that they say hold it
the threads go through each other and
here they're not going through each
other they're hitting each other or
they're
pulling on each other and that's where
the problem comes in
the key issue is aggregation
or agglomeration or however you want to
say it
you can't see an atom but you can see a
table and you say why can i see the
table
if it's made out of things which are
invisible
the key issue is aggregation
agglomeration you put a whole bunch of
atoms together
you can see the object we can see the
object we can see a table because it's a
bunch of atoms together
but if i take that table apart out there
in the universe right one atom at a time
blah blah blah you know
and i have a gazillion atoms out there i
can't see any
of them and this is the same thing with
the thread
the thread you cannot see obviously is
much smaller than that and we can't see
an atom
much less can you see a thread what
happens the thread
at its level it doesn't have the
property of
touch and it doesn't have the property
where you can see it
but what happens if you put a bunch of
threads together like in the case of a
magnet
where you have a wall of threads that's
when they acquire the property of touch
that we have in our macro
world this is a key point that people
have a lot of trouble understanding
because they're so used to our macro
world where we say well you can either
see it and touch it or you can't
it's black or white that's not the case
in the mother nature's subatomic world
where the thread acquires tangibility
and visibility visibility not but
tangibility
only with agglomeration with aggregation
with many threads
working as a wall okay so you need to
understand that
to grasp the notion of why the thread
and the rope
are invisible and intangible but they
become
visible in intangible when you have many
of them just like with the atom that's
an important
key point that you really got to get
through your head in order to understand
the rope model
going back to magnetism yeah not just
the thread spinning but the magnet
spinning too why do spinning magnets
help produce electricity
well that's that requires a a whole show
we'll skip that question too many
motions yeah
no because you you first have to
understand
what uh you know like you have a
floating magnet for example why does
that magnet float
there's a lot of issues there's another
thing when we're talking about the lhc
thing with all the magnetism going down
to a fine point that's just a billion
ropes threads yeah what you have
uh one of these accelera i worked with
an accelerator known as an
implanter an implanter works at the kilo
electrum vault these guys work at the
giga electron boat that's the only
difference the question of power or you
know how much strength
but this is the issue they're all made
in the same way they have a long beam
line
and around the beam line you have
magnets
okay what is a magnet well it's uh
something that curls
threads around so you're you're twirling
threads
the guys on this side go this way the
guys on this side go that way
and so they they push anything in
between they squeeze it
and they do it from all sides you have
these uh quadrupoles
or maybe even more you have magnets all
around the tunnel
yeah and so it pushes all the uh beam or
whatever
goes in there pushes it inwards into a
pencil
okay and that pencil is what uh
in the case of uh an accelerator right
what you have is electricity essentially
what is electricity under the rope model
all these atoms are connected there is
no
electron bead that goes from beginning
to end it's just something that's
torquing inside the
the beam line and what the magnets on
the outside do
is crunch that into a pencil like shape
and it's twirling and what they do they
send they have one going in one
direction the other one
counter clockwise right and what they do
they point these two
beams right which are just twirling
shells and they point them at each other
and it's like pointing two drills
against each other so one's going this
way the other guy going that way and you
have all these sparks
and that's what they're observing in
their uh bubble chambers or in their gas
chambers
have you heard about the storm on
neptune the reverse direction of
movement
storm on neptune stormy on neptune no no
no
other there's all kinds of things
there's all kinds of activity going on
in the solar system in every planet i
mean you know
uh we had uh what was it uh this uh
schumacher uh
um comet that fell
into jupiter finally it was going around
and finally jupiter caught it fell
into it when they filmed all that great
show
they just swallowed it jupiter
you know the god he swallowed this
comment i think we're running out of
questions
but it's coming down to i guess we're
back to exist does fire
exists the fire has shaved no no
reactions
fire fire is a concept remember fire is
combustion chemical reactions
well again it's a reaction if it's a
reaction it's a happening it's an event
it's a phenomenon phenomenon don't exist
what's the other word we use if we're
not using it we don't
use our phenomena it's a behavior so you
don't say a behavior exists
not in physics that's okay in philosophy
well in psychology and psychiatry you
can say that well he has
his behavior exists we can't say that in
science but then what would we
that's ordinary you don't use the word
exist or real you just say
this is the behavior this is the
behavior that we've
this is how he behaves this is a
behavior that we
a pattern that we've noticed yeah let me
let me give you an analogy so that you
it puts it in the proper context we
don't say we don't say
the orbit of jupiter we say
jupiter orbits that's the way you say it
in physics
and this is similar very similar you
don't say
the ex the behavior exists or
no you say he behaves this way
so you got to change your language when
you're talking science in ordinary
speech we we use the word exist in many
ways and we don't care but if
if you're going to talk uh philosophy if
you're going to talk science science uh
physics
you got to use the proper language you
can't say the behavior exists you say
it's a habit you can't really talk about
a chemical reaction existing or being
real or any of that it's just a
happening
it's a behavior that we've noticed but
the objects are what are real
or exist that's one of the other one is
you got to use the correct language
that's why language is important people
don't give
importance in language say oh you're
doing semantics bill yeah it's semantics
but science is
semantics we have to communicate our
mechanisms we have to communicate our
ideas
our explanations our theories that's why
science is 100
semantics you got to get the semantics
right
have you ever made an animation of a
cylindrical magnet
uh no no i haven't done that i want to
do that also a ball
oh yeah i guess it would be down to a
fine point in the center no no because
we got these mapped by the way we do
have
i haven't done it but they haven't
mapped the typical
magnet is the bar magnet the squarish
rectangular magnet but they've uh mapped
the
magnetic field of a ball which is the
earth
the earth has that you know more or less
uh
the ball shaped magnetic field
and they also done it with cylinders so
it's a question of
getting the pattern in and just
replacing
the lines of force faraday's lines of
force
replacing them with threads with
physical threads those are physical
threads for else you're putting spirits
in that same region
you know if the threat is going to cause
a force there had better be something in
there otherwise you're introducing
spirits in
angels how does a tesla coil magnify
an electromagnetic field for lack of a
better term
you're putting more atoms you're putting
more if you have a coil and now you're
gonna
not a tesla coil especially but any coil
and
because i think faraday already did that
and you put a uh
iron in there it increases the magnetic
field why because
what you did is put more atoms in there
that are now the atoms are aligned
okay they're aligned they're aligned
with a magnetic field and all you did is
just put more atoms
meaning you have more threads in there
moving around that's why it's increased
no
there's no mystery to it under the rope
model
how how would all the atoms to form a
storm
oh i guess we're talking about the pole
root
pole shifting of neptune was it
well no uh the i think the poles might
reverse like i think this
they say like 26 million years
the earth turns around dark storm on
neptune reverses direction
possibly shedding a fragment of
i guess it's a it's a nasa.gov article
yeah
okay it's possible uh i mean those are
specific questions
uh you know of something that happened
in the solar system i mean you have all
kinds of activity you have
some volcanic activity out here and
there how well do you speak and
understand german crusoe
oh great yeah
uh behavior is an alternative to exist
in philosophy
okay now starts the spanish
i hope you too see that this has not
been resolved i mean it kind of has been
resolved in the sense that we
we don't say phenomena or real or
phenomena exist
we would just say we just talk about the
phenomenon itself
it's like it's like what bill said about
the orbit of
uh yeah you don't say there is an orbit
or
mars orbiting orbit cannot be the now in
in a
sentence you got to use the the object
in physics it would be jupiter orbits
orbits is what it's doing
and in the case of uh exists the same
thing for philosophy you don't say
the behavior exists or love exists you
say
he is doing love he is doing this
behavior you would put in that term you
you put the noun
first and then the verb which is
typically what
people say exists you put it as the verb
you put is the action so
so you don't say love exists yeah noun
defying
yeah because then you're you're known
yeah you're making love into a noun and
now
and love is not a noun for the purposes
of science
only in ordinary speech is love a noun
intelligence a noun in uh in
science those are verbs and you can't
put verb as a noun
in science that's that's the rationale
the irrational part of language that we
have today
how would all the atoms that form a
storm the size of a planet can suddenly
reverse 180 degrees in the rope
hypothesis i guess we're talking about
uh pole shifting they talk about that
like as well remember remember the only
difference
between the north and the south pole of
a magnet
the uh threads come into the south pole
on the top part right on both really
through the end but
they go in opposite directions like one
is clockwise the other one is
counterclockwise but to go into the
south pole they come out of the north
pole if you want to reverse polarity
let's assume by some
external mechanism you want to change
polarities i'm sure you can do that and
all you're doing is just changing the
direction of the threads in the opposite
direction
for example if you have a small magnet
and a big met in
in the presence of a big magnet you know
that
big magnet because it's much more
powerful can move the threads maybe in
the opposite direction
and a case in point is um an iron filing
okay iron filing if you take it it
doesn't have any
magnetism but you put it in a magnetic
field like close to a magnet
and in suddenly it increases
the magnetic field of that magnet
because the magnetic field of the magnet
started moving the threads around of the
iron filing it magnetized the
iron filing what direction in the
direction in which the
magnetic field was flowing but you put
that whole system now
in the presence of a bigger much bigger
magnet the the earth
and let's say it's going in the opposite
direction it's going to overrule that
and
force the threats to go in the opposite
direction because it's it just
aligns every atom to move in the
opposite direction
so you can change the magnetic field
from north to south south to north
simply by putting it into
a situation which a bigger magnet or a
much stronger magnetic field
has an influence over it are you willing
to answer questions which are not
directly related to physics
uh well depending what uh i don't know
yeah sure whatever i guess extinction
would fall under that yeah yeah
extinction is a fair game you didn't
even talk about other animals extinction
you just talked about human extinction
didn't you yeah
in general but you know like i always
say you got to do
extinction 101 before you do extinction
102. 102 is human extinction 101 is
past extinctions the ones we've
certified already we see those bones in
the rock we say well these animals are
no longer around
we gotta explain that first we gotta
have a mechanism for
for extinct animals then we can apply
that
you know whatever theory you come up
with mechanism you can apply that to man
are there any philosophers that you can
recommend uh yeah my son here
he's a great philosopher
um explain the rice experiment the
results in love
improving the lifespan oh i've heard of
that one where
they take i don't know how true it is
but it's
it's a where you take two plants i think
i guess it was grown with rice i wasn't
sure
and you love one more thing yeah you get
one you tell one that you love it and
what not
that that's that's a non-belief right
well i don't know maybe i'd have to find
out but
i don't i don't do philosophy by the way
you know i'm not interested in that
subject at all i i do a lot of history
but i don't put it on my channel in
general i do that
that's my hobby and i stay away from it
because it takes too much of my time
so why did napoleon go to water you
never answered that one
i'm still working on why caesar went to
england you know
we're running out of questions yeah
bring back morons
i have a question what does the edge of
the universe look like of the matter in
the universe look like
uh i uh i always say that the edge of
the universe okay the edge of the
universe
is magnetism it's got to have threads
sweeping around so if you want to know
what the edge of the universe looks like
just go out outside one night and
there's got to be a magnetic field that
you can't see
but if you had god's eyes you would see
this magnetic field surrounding the
earth
that's what the edge of the universe
looks like a magnetic field
on the last bit of matter out there
i mean but it'd be weird because if the
swinging of the
threads of the magnetic fields
works by centrifugal force which is what
we're implying essentially
centrifugal right if you swing a thing
around the ring the reason
no no no no no no because um
gravity only has an effect on the atoms
that from where the field comes out of
so it doesn't have an effect on the
field like in
mathematical physics where they say that
gravity bends light
uh not true
only only when you drink too much then
it does bend like your light starts
bending in one direction
i guess we're running out of questions
do you have any questions for them uh
no but we'll see you in one year i'll
see you in the year 2021
okay folks uh we'll call the end of the
year and we'll see you next year
so you gotta wait one year to see me
again okay next year we'll see you again
and hopefully you have a new grand new
year's despite
the fact that uh this was the lost years
uh
this corona stuff or whatever or whether
it's true or not the
economic effects were real no doubt
about that
so we'll see what happens right next
year real or the
economic existed yeah they existed
we'll see you next year folks bye guys
have a good one